[Music]
let's go e4
okay
so we're sticking to our guns we're
sticking to our gun and and the great
thing about the four night scotch
is that you do not need a separate
system against the petrog you can just
go knight c3
and black is of course very likely to go
knight c6 and now we go into the four
night scotch
against which so far nobody has really
even played the main line which was
bishop before and still still we see
knight takes before which is a mistake
and a lot of people still attracted to
this idea of chasing white's queen which
we've discussed several times
and already black has to be very careful
d6 is almost the only move here
otherwise we shove her upon down black's
throat no this is already almost losing
so as i as i've indicated now we go e5 i
won't re-explain this we've had probably
already three or four games that go just
like this
queen e7 okay
this is getting worse and worse for
black
couldn't get the staff or yeah and it's
an ansi stafford idea
okay so what to do here
now i'm quite confident that some of you
guys are probably
yeah bishop g5 is a great move
so how do i explain this bishop g5
doesn't actually threaten to take the
knight immediately but bishop g5 is a
second order threat if we play bishop g5
what we're actually threatening is to
castle queenside and then we'll be
winning the night so bishop g5 is a
great move
um but we can also play this very simple
we can play bishop out to e2
and cancel this pin and then force the
knight back to g8 which looks
absolutely atrocious for black
and we can play bishop e3 with the same
exact idea
i also like bishop e3 from the
perspective of preparing queen side
castles
so both bishop g5 and bishop e2 are
phenomenal moves
i feel like a quicker win
could be yielded by bishop g5 i i want
to go bishop g5 i feel like we're gonna
we're gonna go straight for black's
throat here
i like bishop g5 too because this
creates a a monumental challenge for
black
in the sense that we're threatening to
castle and then the knight is going to
be lost
and the thing to understand is that if
black plays well if black plays h6 here
and we'll cross that bridge if we get
there
black plays h6 we have a move that
essentially wins on the spot
we've got maybe even several moves that
went on the spot
queen e6 our opponent is totally off off
off their rocker
what to do now
well we already know what to do now
so
bishop c4 there's a funny move queen g4
and even then we could trade queens and
go like knight d5 and then black ant
defense so it's a disaster but we don't
even need to play
okay so bishop c4 queen g4
let me think for a second that position
i'm going to try to find a knockout
there there there
it it's not quite as convincing as i'd
like it to be
yeah i think the simplest the simplest
thing we can do here
is just to castle just to complete our
development
and and to reinforce the threat of he
takes f6
easy does it in such positions you
really don't need any kind of
extravagant idea
you don't need any extravagant ideas
now here we have a very high level move
i'm going to warn everybody this is not
a move that i would expect
necessarily a
you know it
and this i don't mean this kind of
setting you know like this is a pretty
master level idea so
in probably most of you are thinking
about queen f4
the way that
most people would approach this position
is to say okay queen is hanging
we need to move the queen to a square
such that it protects the e5 pawn
okay queen e4 blunders the queen so the
only square available is queen f4 now
does queen of four have any issues the
only issue with queen f4 actually there
are no issues with queen f4 and queen of
four is completely winning
but i want to show you guys a an idea
that i think is cooler and more
instructive and that is queen h4
which deliberately gives up the e5 pawn
and it looks like black takes on e5 and
then black is ready to castle kingside
and unfortunately after queen takes e5
we are unable to play rookie one because
our bishop isn't developed yet so the e1
square isn't protected
but after queen takes e5 we have a very
very nice follow-up that if i've
calculated it correctly wins the game on
the spot
knight okay unfortunately our opponent
doesn't even let us demonstrate it
that's sad
but it is what it is knight g4
okay now we um
we collect
now we collect and we need to target the
c7 pawn how do we do that
we go knight d5
and if black castles king side and this
is i will admit probably not ideal on
mice on my end the way i play this is
maybe not perfect but
it's
for those people on youtube it's it's
three in the morning so i'll give myself
a pass
and then of course we can play and i
take c7 if we want yeah our opponent is
playing if i may be honest our opponent
is playing so badly
that like we have so many options on
every move and even i'm getting
overwhelmed by the amount sheer amount
of different winning possibilities we
have
it's just
yeah i mean i mean this is
i guess an effective way of playing for
black
well i'm saying i'm telling you like it
is our phone is just not playing very
well
i'm sure they're trying
bishop f2
i didn't say that he's not trying
but
okay
this no comments
no comments um
yeah i mean i don't know not not his or
her best day
so
[Music]
again you can see that even at this
level almost everybody goes for this
position knight takes d4 which is a
mistake and then follows up with another
mistake allowing e5 i went through this
many times you guys can consult
previous speedrun games for an
explanation of why this is already bad
for black
but the bottom line here is that um
yeah i think maybe bishop b2 would be a
more prudent option
forcing the knight back to g8 and then
we can go knight t5 etc
this is just horrible
but we decided on bishop g5 and then
castles
bishop c5 queen h4 now the only idea and
maybe i overplayed this a little bit
after queen takes c5 we have a pretty
subtle move
that i believe wins the game immediately
so obviously we want to put a rook on e1
right and in order to do what we need to
do that what we need to develop the
bishop now the question is where do we
develop it and in order to figure that
out you need to understand the black
wants to castle
and you need to develop your bishop such
that
you prevent black from being able to
castle
i.e bishop d3 is the move bishop d3 with
the idea of meeting castles with bishop
takes f6 and queen takes h7 checkmate
um and the cooler thing
is that black has a tactic here notice
that the bishop on g5 it's a type two
undefended piece and it's being aimed at
by white black screen what's defending
it well it's white's queen and you know
that the queen is an incredibly
incredible liability as a defender so
black has the tactic bishop takes f2
and this looks like trouble because if
you take on f2 then black takes on g5
and then black is able to castle and all
of a sudden black is up two puns but it
is in this position that we have a
really sexy move
white to play and win
you got it rook he won anyway
rook he won anyway
and maybe i think bishop oh bishop f6
loses a queen bishop f6 queen e3 check
and then bishop takes h4 so that's a
trap the move is rook he won
like i don't get it bishop takes h what
am i talking about well here we take the
queen with check
and then we recapture black's bishop and
we're up a piece
and overwhelmingly winning because
black's not developed and if black takes
any one then we play rook takes you in
because the link between the queen and
the rook we win black's queen
just a cool idea rook hu1 anyway this is
not very common
and then we hit the queen and we win the
game
if anybody didn't follow this line
please let me know i want to explain it
in a way such that everybody
can follow it but the move is okay and
what makes this possible is the fact
that the f2 pawn has disappeared when
the f2 pawn is on the board rook hu1
there's no contact between the queen and
a piece that's on e1
which is i think one of the things that
makes chess beautiful like our opponent
is almost doing us a service by taking
on f2
queenie one by black that we take with
check
this is check i i know what you're
thinking but this is a check
why not rook d one no rook d1 is the
same thing it doesn't matter
it does not matter in this game i mean
it's just a little more elegant to play
rook hu-1 somehow i don't know i don't
know how to explain just a little bit
more
culture in russian you can say it's a
little more cultured to the lyric hu1
maybe f4 instead of bishop d3 f4 is also
possible i'm sure white is winning this
way in that way black is so undeveloped
here that there is no way that he should
be able to survive
uh the onslaught in either case
aesthetic is better yeah
the aesthetic is better and it's just
best practice to go rook hu1 because rd1
allows queen takes c1 with check
okay and once we go knight t5
to be honest with you i i was a little
bit concerned about our opponent
castling here and my idea was to drop
the knight back to f4 in order to
try to sever the contact between black's
queen and the knight on g4
queen f5 there's bishop d3
with all sorts of skewers and nightmares
otherwise we capture the knight and we
emerge up a piece we also can take on c7
now that i think about it
so
thank you jack
not falling for that one
yeah no knight c7 is possible it's just
that there's queen takes e5 here
and this gets a little bit messy knight
takes f2 remember the black also can to
to can tango it takes two to tango
so in this position we can actually play
queen takes g4 and then try to go bishop
f6 but
this still needs to be calculated so i
think knight f4 is the simpler move
anyways i mean this is all very
one-sided because black is so
undeveloped everything that ends up
tends to work here
okay
i think we're gonna call it a night guys
these were two pretty solid games we're
almost 1700
and i want to remind people watching on
youtube that i've you can tell that i'm
playing a little faster in the opening
and i'm explaining
less of the basics in the opening
um and that is
what you know
what happens in the speedrun as we go as
we rise my commentary level reflects the
level that i'm currently at
no i did finish the game i mean once
black blundered the fork it's it's game
over we just win the queen with check
all right guys the next speedrun is up
on youtube so please
feel free to check it out would love if
you subscribe to my youtube we're
closing in on 250k subs we're like 2 000
away
it's a huge milestone for me so
every sub counts i would really
appreciate it
um it's not a million but it's you know
it's a quarter of the way there
all right thanks everybody
appreciate the support later everybody
hans and niemann all right bye thanks
for hanging out
[Music]
you